no they don't understand
the value do you want to get a snack
actually
somebody has a whiny country voice
ariana grande and john legend have had
enough of kelly clarkson and blake
shelton's shenanigans and straight up
just walked off set
i feel like john and i are parents on a
vacation or a field trip with our
children and you know i like country
music
and they're just like fighting over toys
and stuff during the latest round of
blind auditions blake and kelly were
both trying to win over contestant lana
scott a country singer who wowed them
with her cover of kelsey ballerini's a
hole in the bottle
[Music]
and that's when the voice coaches got
into it
that is a song kelly won't know this
about kelsey ballerini i toured with her
she sat right here in this chair
i hired kelsey last season to fill in
for kelly
i am friends with her and texted her and
she came to fill in i watched it i put
the deal together
yeah john and ari tried to get a word in
but it wasn't happening i don't lie i
just want to leave with that
he does
so ari she suggested they take a break
kelly watched a documentary on country
music how can i ever compete with that
can ariana can i talk at all anybody who
says no they don't understand the value
do you want to get a snack actually
somebody has a whiny country voice do
you want anyone anything that would be
alarming to me you know what i'm saying
that's when the grammy winners blessed
us with this memeable moment
[Applause]
when they returned lana had a tough
choice to make and ultimately
she chose team blake there's nothing
better than being ganged up on by all
three of the other coaches and still
getting the artists
oh kelly's so mad
e.t caught up with the voice coaches
leading up to monday's season 21
premiere where john kelly and blake said
the god is a woman singer is a major
threat
especially because she has such a loyal
fan base
she is hugely talented hugely successful
and has legions and legions of fans that
know how to use the internet and vote
we always come out like you know in like
like i'll go john goes whatever and
blake's usually lasts he gets the most
screams and and and well
and then he used to he used to do and
then all of a sudden he was like can
ariana go before me because they lose
their mind
it's embarrassing to follow her but
that's why we enjoy it see we wanted it
to stay that way because we enjoyed it
my lack of celebrity celebrities
when ariana goes in front of a celebrity
yeah i think i have a hearing problem
what are your fan clubbers called
where
my fans literally don't even have a name
but
there aren't any i was a huge fan of the
voice i have watched many seasons and i
love watching the show it always has the
best energy and it's just such
like wholesome inspiring television and
i love seeing the different voices and
watching so many people start careers
for themselves it's like a beautiful
amazing thing and i've always been a fan
and i feel so grateful to be here
[Music]